hello I'm Marcus Eriksen and this is my
formula one school so you need to
practice and practice a lot and for
example when you start your career it's
Cocotte so make sure you're an expert of
goecart before you have any dreams of
formula one after that you need to also
of course have fun and enjoy what you're
doing but again you need to practice and
practice and practice and finally you
need to also have the ability Southside
attract it's not only about the driving
but you need to be also very good with
sponsors with media and with everything
else around the track with your team
with your engineers to help them build a
car for you
so it's very important to not only be a
good driver but also a good person
outside the track in Formula One that's
my school